So as I know from the last slide, right?
Once we start thinking about goal
abstraction and sort of all of these
functions or modules or
procedures running at the same time,
what you really have done is turn
this into a problem of arbitration.
By the way this does have a name.
I really like the name, it's called
modular reinforcement learning.
And that just sort of captures the idea
that we divided the world into a bunch
of modules or
what we might call options or
what we might call
temporally extended actions.
And these things always have
associated with them goals.
They're always trying to do something or
to accomplish something.
They're different models and
with operating system, and
we need to decide which program
we're going to let run next.
And there are lots of ways
you might imagine doing this.
Here are three of the more popular
ones each of which has strings and
drawbacks and they're kind of the things
that you would come up with if you were
given five minutes on a test
to come up with something.
So here are the various
arbitration techniques.
So the simplest one is greatest
mass Q learning which well,
Michael what do you think that means?
>> It means Greatest Mass Q learning.
>> So we have Q functions maybe for
each of the individual subtasks and
we say well whoever's got the highest
Q value gets to take the next action.
>> That's close.
So the first thing you said is right.
Since each of these things are their own
little goals running around they're like
their own little RL bots or agents,
then each of them has a Q function.
And what greatest mass Q function does
is it adds up all of the Q functions.
So for the state that we happen
to be in, add up the Q value for
every state action pair.
And whichever one is the largest
that's the one that we execute.
So I was saying whichever Q function
has the largest value you're actually
saying which action after combining
the Q functions has the largest rate.
>> Right.
>> So it's sort of like they're voting.
>> That's exactly right it's exactly
like they're voting so I say that
the Q value of taking a particular
action in any state is actually the sum
of all the Q values for
each of the agents indexed here by i.
>> And then we take, we go greedy.
>> I picked the action that has
the most mass across all the agents.
>> Okay, so then why is it Q then?
Why isn't it just greatest
action mass or something?.
>> Well the reason you have it as
Q-learning is because you assume there
was Q-learning going on and you're using
the Q-function to determine how to vote.
So that's exactly why
it's called Q-learning
because there's a Q-function involved.
So this is adding everything up and
it does sort of exactly
what you would expect.
Basically everyone votes and whichever
wins has the biggest vote wins.
>> So I want to say that
the the modules are voting but
they're voting on different actions.
And whichever action has
the largest number of votes wins.
>> Right, I'm sorry,
that's what I meant to say.
What did I say?
>> Okay.
>> Well it sounded like,
it was interpretable as the whichever
Q-module gets the most
votes gets to decide.
>> I'm sorry.
Yeah, so that's actually closer
to what you were describing.
>> Yeah I know.
>> But yeah so
here all you're doing is
you're voting for each action.
That's the greatest mass Q-learning and
you just go from there.
And that's neat and
kind of makes sense if you assume
sort of they're all care about
some ultimate goal together.
But people have observed that that could
be bad because it might not be good for
any particular agent, right?
So imagine that I have a couple of,
I have ten agents, they're ten actions,
and each one strongly believes
in a subset of those actions.
But they're different ones.
So each one being the different action.
And so, or better yet, there are five,
there are ten actions and
there's five agents.
And there's an action that is the fifth
choice of every one of those agents.
But because the fifth choice of every
one of those agents it's the one
that ends up getting the most mass and
so
you haven't really satisfied
any of the subgoals.
>> Yeah I mean I could see that as being
a bad thing or I could see that as being
good thing right because it is choosing
that action not just because it's
bad it's just that actually because
it makes everybody a little happy.
Instead of making some
people really unhappy.
Right but you can construct examples
where sort of everyone's least favorite
choice will still end up being the one
with the most votes if nobody agrees
on anything else.
But that's okay I mean it's still as you
say it's a reasonable thing to do under
lots of circumstances or just happen to
be cases where doesn't always work which
would there's no free lunch so it's
not surprising that that's the case.